let's talk about the first story
we have this from military.com
new york governor may deploy national
guard to assist with health care vaccine
mandate now i got to say first and
foremost this is a a repost essentially
from the associated press that ap writes
it and then it gets picked up by a bunch
of different outlets
but i noticed that there you know based
on what kathy hoechel said governor of
new york versus what they're writing in
news stories i think they're kind of
playing this soft
she may deploy the national guard to
assist with healthcare vaccine mandate
it's not her first plan and it's only in
the event she has to fire all these
people over the vaccine mandate which
sounds like their intent is to do it we
heard something similar in the uk when
they said we may
deploy the army to drive trucks the uk
one of the officials said we have no
plans to do this
but we're preparing to do it you see
it's word games when she comes out and
says that she's going to enact a state
of emergency granting her the power to
deploy medically trained national guard
because they're going to be firing
nurses i mean that's straight up stating
their intent to do so
i don't think it's fair to then be like
they might not do it anyway well a lot
of people might not do anything you know
michael bloomberg comes out and says i'm
going to attack soda he might do it well
he literally said he was going to do it
so let's talk about what their intent is
and and the line they're drawing as well
as how far they're pushing us towards
authoritarianism so what i see is truly
interesting about this
and what's happening and i think it's in
massachusetts i'm not sure maybe it's
rhode island where they're getting rid
of the where they're they're not getting
they're sending in the national guard to
drive uh buses for school for uh school
children
because of the problems caused by the
politicians destroying the private
sector like this is the perfect example
we're going to mandate a medical
procedure with no exceptions no testing
exceptions just straight up do it
without legislate without legislative
approval then when the market collapses
they're going to send in government
agents to replace them it sounds a bit
like um
you know i don't want to say fascism
because that that's that's that implies
like kind of an ultra traditionalist
this is kind of like chinese state
communism style yeah so
you're an economist robert what are your
thoughts on uh on this stuff yeah i what
i was going to say is exactly what you
anticipated that yes standard operating
procedure the government lays down some
legislation you're saying wasn't even
legislation necessarily just make some
rules edicts yes
causes problems and then says oh well
gee now that there's this problem the
free market can't solve it so i guess we
got to come in as the savior and i don't
like this idea that oh whenever
something isn't getting done just send
in the military because they know how to
do everything apparently and as we know
if you want to get something done well
and efficiently and with courtesy you
send in troops like who else would you
want to be you know driving your your
school kids around
the national guard this reminds me of a
ryan long sketch
where it was antifa window repair
so it's like they they dress up like
auntie phone go around in the ride smash
windows and the next day show up and say
hey we can fix your windows that's
basically what we're seeing they're like
unfortunately all these nurses have
chosen to do the have not chosen to do
the right thing oh no now the government
has to come in to clean up the mess
so we're seeing it with a lot of things
i mean
in terms of the authoritarian takeover
like i don't know if you've been seeing
what's going on in australia
have you been yeah yeah yeah do you see
this video's going viral uh i don't know
if you saw ian or lydia where it's like
a guy sitting at a fountain smoking a
cigarette and the cops come up and just
throw them the ground
and you know they're like there's like
seven cops
and they're like you know this woman's
yelling what are you doing leave malone
and he has no reason to be here it's
like he went out for a walk it wasn't
wearing a mask he was smoking a
cigarette and the cops were like we
don't care
so that's that's kind of the direction
we're heading in but it's so it's it's
interesting that we're seeing a
combination of well maybe it's not
interesting the the government takeover
is hitting both the you know the economy
and law enforcement i guess so we're
getting edict and we're getting our
we're having our economy shut down
so yeah my concern beyond you know the
specifics of this and the injustice to
the people involved is just the broader
point i to me i think what they're
trying to do is get the public
more familiar with just seeing guys with
big guns walking around you know taking
charge of the situation like moving it
towards what would be called a police
state so something that you know decades
ago americans would have thought they'll
never happen here
they're not in other words they're not
just going to say oh we're doing this
because it's big brother here's watching
you they they can't literally go from
that from tuesday to a wednesday but
they do this so you know oh national
guard we'll know they're just driving
school buses because you know those
people won't get vaccinated so of course
they got to do that and just get us used
to
seeing
guys and you know camel walking around
yeah isn't it amazing how kind of
desensitized everyone's become to like a
lot of the stuff i remember i was in new
york and i was walking past grand
central station and the cops that are
there they've they're like fully decked
out in full armor they look like
stormtroopers and they've got you know
probably selective fire rifles of some
sort and i was just like man that's a
crazy sight and they have dogs and
they're like standing next to the
entrances and i'm like do we really need
that i guess i mean
yeah i would yeah i was so i went to
grad school nyu so in 911 you know i was
i was there i mean i wasn't literally i
was across new jersey but yeah for
uh i think months after i forget exactly
when they phase it out but yeah there
were you know armored personnel carriers
just on the streets guys walking around
with big guns and
you're sort of used to it you know and i
realized like oh this is what america
would look like you know down the road
if americans let it go that way and it
looks like they're they are letting it
go that way yeah and then you know i've
been hearing from a lot of people a lot
of uh
military officers resigning a lot of
police officers are always on that's
another big story a couple dozen i guess
dozens they say of police in
massachusetts are resigning over the
vaccine mandates
so
i mean
can i just ask you and i think you
alluded to it a minute ago the thing
about this that i haven't seen more
people bringing up is just
on its surface so i i understand that
yeah especially in health care you know
people with certain conditions they you
know they might be genuinely concerned i
don't want you know a nurse dealing with
me who hasn't been vaccinated but
wouldn't it also be good just to show no
i had this like that i have antibodies
like to me that would be a more
important test to say yeah i had coveted
three months ago i beat it
and yet i don't even see that being
discussed well let alone like addressed
and dealt with when they say we don't
care about negative tests when they say
they don't care about antibodies
they're saying this is nothing to do
with the infection has everything to do
with control right i mean they can come
out and say all day and night that this
is about public health and i'm like then
wouldn't you actually follow the science
but they don't they don't do that the
science
uh the science in many instances there
has been a lot of science that
should and
uh could and should be questioned yet
what do you get censorship
so all right shout out to ryan long
again
because he has a sketch where uh he just
put out today i think called like trust
the experts or whatever where he comes
out and he's like all the experts agree
and then you know his buddy walks up i
think danny's name and he's like i'm an
expert and i read the data and came to a
slightly different conclusion than ryan
long was punching him and he's like shut
up and kicking him he's like the experts
agree that's basically what we're seeing
what i was going to say about the police
resigning over vaccine mandates
you mentioned you know people getting
used to seeing you know cops out in the
street and things like this
it really is amazing to me how far we've
gone
where i can talk to my friends who
aren't very political and i'll say like
if i would have told you three years ago
they'd bar people from leaving their
homes that they'd be mandating you get a
medical procedure albeit a small one i'm
not saying they're gonna cut out your
appendix or anything
otherwise you can't work
and that you know we'd see widespread
riots and there would be cotton nobody
would believe it nobody believe it if i
told you that the government would
deploy you know tens of thousands of
national guards surrounding the capitol
with fences they'd be like ah get out of
here if i said there'd be people
struggling no one would believe any of
it it's all been so chaotic people are
desensitized and now we're at the point
where
the good cops who are like you can't
make us do this and this is not
constitutional are all resigning but
there are cops who are staying and those
cops are not going to be the good cops
who are like i'm not going to you know
enforce that one that crosses the line
what we're gonna be left with is a
military of a bunch of people saying
like i don't know just following orders
and a bunch of police saying oh just
following orders and then what do we get
yeah i think that's what concerns me too
you know about like the the advertising
like the you know the woke advertising
for the cia and all that and they're
that they're
making it the case that after they get
rid of you know the questionables and
the people with these domestic ties and
so forth that they're gonna replace them
with the right kind of people who are
then going to implement these because
right now you're right the sort of
top-down commands that they want to eat
issue
there'd be a lot of resistance or
hesitancy to you know enforce this stuff
but i think they're looking ahead and
saying no we got plans in place so that
five years from now the personnel
staffing these organizations are not
going to be the ones that were here so
they will follow those orders is it one
thing that's interesting to me to me
though is that often um
powerful interests special interests
politicians use economics as a means of
controlling the system right how do you
make how do you how do you make someone
behave the way you want well you tax
their item michael bloomberg was like
we're going to tax large sodas so you
know people are stupid and fat so that
way they won't buy them and things like
that tax cigarettes tax gasoline
in this instance they're going over
authoritarianism you know i wonder if
would you agree that they typically use
economic power to pressure people well i
think you're right even in this instance
though in other words instead of
washington just saying every american
you know except for many people with
certain exceptions because vulnerability
has to get this vaccine no we're not
saying that we're just saying if you
want to work at a larger organization
yeah you're afraid you're free to might
have a food yeah so you're free to go
into the woods right so even i agree
with that you are yeah and and that's
also like with the big tech and so like
that's part of the way they're they're
doing this as a sort of an end run and
there's coercion involved don't get this
isn't like a free market outcome but
yeah i think you're right that they
realize it's easier you know to get
someone to say well my boss is making me
do it and i need my job i gotta support
my kids whereas if we're just a matter
of paying a fine and going to jail for
30 days they might you know stand up to
the man and this is the crazy thing
about it it's that we've become uh
accustomed to a climate
and
uh
locked into in a sense right
people are so used to living in
climate-controlled homes with
refrigerators and microwave stoves
natural gas easy access at supermarkets
they're like i can't give that up my
kids need this and i'm like i don't know
300 years ago some dude was like forging
through the weeds for food for his
family and
that that that being said people today
don't really have the ability to go and
forage and farm on their own because
land is owned and controlled by
everybody so we're at this point now
where the planet's basic basically been
labeled you know i claimed by enough
people or interests
that if you did leave your job what can
you do i mean theoretically you can go
to like charon in mexico and then start
figuring things out you can go to the
middle of nowhere but if you have a
family you can't just take a claim
anymore you can't just go to landing
back okay i'm gonna farm here and
survive nope they locked you in
so what do you do
well you can start a new career path as
a internet video blogger
[Laughter]
so hopefully you did it two years ago
because you know now you don't have much
time to get it going if you're gonna
have to resign from your job that that i
don't know if you saw the conversation i
had with jack murphy what was that that
was that was a week and a half ago or so
something
he was talking about how his kid wants
to play you know college sports varsity
sports and then college sports and now
they're saying well you got to get
vaccinated so he's like it's tyranny he
doesn't think the vaccine's going to
hurt his kid anything like that he just
thinks the government's trying to force
him to do it and it's a difficult
position where he doesn't want to tell
his kid not to play baseball and my
attitude was like i think you should
tell your kid to play baseball i think
if you truly believe in it you should
stand up and say i'm not no if there's
you know the government isn't my doctor
and shouldn't tell me you know what i'm
supposed to be doing
the issue you know much bigger than just
baseball is
i saw i saw a video of uh it was a
medical worker saying
you know if i have to support my family
i can quit and then we're completely
broke or i can get the vaccine
and so they're like i guess i have no
choice and that's where people are at
the government is is not only
you know i think this is a sign of how
much how how bad it's really really
going to get
if they have people
so constrained and so scared that
they'll undergo a medical procedure
then
what else can they do
get off the central electric grid for
starters get off the centralized fiat
currency grid secondly so that means
crypto solar power grow your own food
get off the centralized food grid
those are three things you can do
homesteading
you know getting get a place out in the
middle of nowhere grow your own food get
some chickens work on the big fans of
chickens have have small companies let's
do lots and lots of small companies
yeah but like what do people do you know
like how much work being done by people
is actually contributing to the lives of
individuals like food production and you
know things like that
fuel
most people like
to be fair like we produce
a relatively small amount of
goods for people i mean i guess people
can say that
thought and planning and this is the
kind of stuff that goes into fixing
economies and making people live better
so it's good but like we're not fixing
any toilets we're not growing any bread
we're not feeding anybody so i have many
friends who work in the service industry
whether it's in food or like like i used
to work in a hospital and they're saying
that they're being required to get the
vaccine and when i read the numbers of
americans who live from paycheck to
paycheck it is not surprising to me at
all that they're able to require this of
people who really don't want it like i
had a facebook friend who recently got
it and she's like you win joe biden
because i didn't i have to do this to
keep my career i was like that's really
sad you shouldn't have to do that but i
also know that you have three kids your
husband can't work and you know that if
you don't take this shot you will have
to find an entirely different career
this job pays much better than working
as a waitress or something so i
completely understand it's a hard
situation i don't like that we're being
put in it but we're going to figure out
how to stand up to it
yes you guys are right that it's not
literally impossible
to uh you know avoid this stuff but also
too just like you're saying like that's
part of the reason i think that they
monopolize the money supply is because
they knew you know what better way to
put the screws to people right and so
you know their high income tax and wow
well let me just you know go outside the
standard health care system well no you
can't because there's the fda the cdc
you can't just open up your own hospital
and say hey here people don't need to be
vaxxed you know this is that ultimately
would be the solution in a genuinely
free society that because you know
people say oh well so should my kids not
you know what if they had the measles or
something you know you're against all
and it's not that there's just some all
you know from on high some right thing
to do it's like each each building or
each organization could set its own
rules like you were saying sports they
could decide you know do the kids you
know need to get something or not
whether to participate and you know that
they would have certain uniform
requirements or whatever couldn't show
up to play naked and play football you
know
of among other reasons because that's
not sanitary right and so it's or kids
bleeding out or something and said no i
want to play it's my decision my dad
said i'm fine you know so there's things
to do and the way to ultimately handle
it is not us making a case by case but
to have the organization set the rules
the problem here is the government has
got its just tentacles and everything so
much that they can kind of force this
outcome thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you